John baptized Jesus go ahead yeah okay
and then he sees the Holy Spirit coming
upon in the shape of a Dove body
shape and then later in mat 11
19 when no I'm sorry in M 112 and 3 yeah
when John the disciples to ask are you
the one or should we expect someone else
exactly so I was going to how is that he
because he already saw the Holy Spirit
coming into him and the father saying
this is my son did Peter James and John
see Jesus transfigure before their eyes
on the Mount of
transfiguration uhhuh did they see Moses
and Elijah
appear yeah they they talking and they
saw the cloud come down and heard the
father's voice audibly say this is my
son whom I love listen to him yes they
did and they still betrayed Jesus and
denied
him
yeah you got your answer
right yeah I'm sorry I G get it I'm
sorry now because you're assuming just
because he saw the Spirit heard God
somehow that's going to make him
infallible impeccable Peter James and
John saw the cloud heard the voice of
the father like John the Baptist did
they saw Moses and Elijah they saw Jesus
transfigured and they still betrayed him
and denied
him when Peter James and John are on the
mountain did Jesus transfigure before
them they saw him shining like the sun
and his clothes whiter than anything on
Earth yeah have you read that yeah I
read that did they see Moses and Elijah
appear yes they did they even want to
build a tent for them to stay did they
see the Cloud come
down yes they did and they heard the
father's voice
audibly yes they did but according to
you if they saw all that then how is it
possible they denied him but they did
deny him why are you shocked that even
the best of saints can be the worst of
Sinners and weaken and lose Faith that's
the entire story of your Bible I just
showed you that they had a similar
experience to John the Baptist and they
still betrayed Christ but you're still
shocked that John could doubt Jesus so
when Moses and Aaron and Israel saw the
pillar of cloud by day Pillar of Fire by
night and saw the 10 plagues and pharaoh
and Egyptians s can you explain to me
would Aaron agree to help the Israelites
fashion a golden calf when the cloud is
right in front of
them yeah you're not getting it because
you have a higher view of man than you
should man left to himself is weak and
carnal and even if God stands before him
he'll betray God it's like Satan
standing before God and still sinning
against God so if God the Father speaks
to you and says to
you this is my son whom I love listen to
him you that's not enough proof that
this is the Son of God and then when
Jesus tells you they're going to kill
him and he'll be raised on a third day
that's still not enough proof to
convince you that it was God's will for
this son to be killed if you're on the
Mount of
transfiguration and you see God come
down in a pillar of cloud and you hear
his voice audibly say this Jesus is my
son whom I love listen to him and you
see Jesus transfigured and his face
shines like the sun and Moses and Elijah
appear and then he tells you right after
that he tells you I'll be betrayed and
killed and they come to arrest him and
kill him would you deny him and betray
him and turn away from him well I don't
think I better than them I think happen
to me you see your question okay so you
answer your question so what makes you
think John is any more special and
Superior to
them
nothing so why do you assume that just
because John encountered God and
miraculous way that would make him
immune in doubting when if you read the
context he's in
prison yeah because okay you get it now
so don't make John more than he is but
now that's assuming that he's sending
the disciples to ask Jesus if he's the
one or should we expect another because
he's doubting see this was an assumption
but even if I go with that
interpretation John is doubting why
would you be shocked you made John more
than he is
and the teaching of the Bible is don't
make any human more than they are
because even the best of Saints on Earth
can commit the worst sins and disappoint
you and break your heart David murdered
a man because he slept with his wife and
got her pregnant he murdered him to
cover the fact he commit adultery so if
you had your hope in David he would have
disappointed you so this is the lesson
don't make them more than they are they
are sinners who apart from me are
nothing but maggots and will betray me
like this and deserve wrath if I don't
sustain them and convict them rebuke
them and chasen them and transform them
you made John more than he is you made
the Baptist much more than he is you got
to now bring him down a notch okay now
that's one you understand now you
understand now that it's possible that
John could start faltering in his faith
because he's human and he's in prison
and he's being mistreated and then
because of that his ful nature come to
the Forefront and got get him to
question the goodness of
Christ yeah I got it probably he's going
to see if he's gonna die for their re
their good reason if we assume that he's
asking because he's doubt he's human
Okay Moses was human Aaron was human
David was human Solomon was human Samson
was human go see what they did Sanson
slept with a prostitute he married a
Philistine woman when you know that's
against God will David committ adultery
murdered the man right Solomon had 700
wives 300 concubines and he worshiped
their gods and goddesses First Kings 11
they're human why you making them more
than they are even after Pentecost when
the spirit filled Peter even after Peter
ended up being
afraid of the crowd of the Jews and Paul
had to rebuke him and condemn him
publicly that's Galatians 2 11-6 even
after Pentecost after being filled with
the spirit after preaching the gospel
after telling the Jews Gentiles don't
need to get circumcised and keep the law
of Moses they keep the law of Christ it
says in Galatians 21-6 when a group of
Jews came from James Peter pulled
himself away from the Gentiles wouldn't
eat with them because he's afraid they'd
be upset so he caved into peer
pressure where do you get that these men
are greater than you think they are
you with me there yeah okay so now did
you understand it's possible John had
doubts okay so
what that's why Jesus says blessed is
the man who does not take offense at me
who doesn't stumble because of me he
doesn't he say that in that same chapter
he goes go and tell John what you see
and here and he points to the Miracles
and then he says blessed is the man who
does not take offense at me who does not
stumble because of me
yeah okay now that's one answer are you
ready for the second answer oh is that
another one yes I'm ready do you
understand now as great as John is he's
still weak and nothing without Jesus
right yes sir and do you now understand
that throughout the scriptures old the
New Testaments you find Saint after
Saint who compromise or succumb to sin
and weakness and do things that are
shameful I'll give you example with
Abraham
Abraham told Sarah this is in Genesis 20
verse 13 he made a covenant with her
wherever we go tell them you're my
sister don't say you're my wife because
if they know you're my wife you're so
beautiful they'll murder me so they can
have you so do me a favor say you're my
sister and Sarah and her love for
Abraham agreed meaning she was willing
to allow men to take her and ravish her
in order to protect Abraham's life so
God had to intervene and save Sarah from
being ravaged by the Pharaoh and
aimik and this is Abraham who's called
the friend of God whom God appeared and
promised him to be the father of many
nations yes where are you getting that
these men are greater than they are you
know when they're great and perfect and
infallible when they enter God's
presence the Saints in heaven the
apostles and the prophets they are now
perfect and
Flawless they are now perfected they
cannot sin and disappoint whereas on
Earth as long as you have sin even the
best of saints can commit the worst of
sins so stop making john more than he is
we got it now yes sir yeah thank you now
let me give you the second
interpretation it's not John is asking
because he's doubting if you actually
read it carefully it's much more deeper
so either explanation there's no problem
John is is about to be killed so now
he's preparing his disciples to follow
Jesus because Jesus must increase he
must
decrease right so he's preparing them
for the next phase in their life follow
him he is the one so go to him and ask
him are you the one and he's going to
convince you he's the one so when I die
you become his disciples that's the
answer that's a beautiful answer
he was doing it for their sake go ask
him is he the one or shall we expect
another because he knew the Lord would
confirm to them I am the one and he did
it by the miracle so now when John is
killed they now know he is the one that
John pointed to the Messiah the Lord God
and the Flesh and we are to be his
disciples so either interpretation
what's the problem
I didn't expect that
one because is John about to
die he's going to be killed in prison
right yeah so his disciples they're
going to be scattered who should they
follow the one that I've been bearing
witness to the Lamb of
God and if you have any doubt he's the
one go and ask him are you the one or
should we expect someone else and then
they went while he's doing Miracles and
the Miracles convince them he's the one
so when they go back to John see follow
him when I
die yeah he's leaving them in good hands
say it again he's leaving them in good
hands yes because he's gonna die and he
said in John 3 remember in John 3 22 all
the way if you read to 31 when everyone
went to Jesus to be
baptized they said John the one you bore
witness to they're all going to him and
they're all being baptized by him and
what does he say in John 3:27 to 28 he
goes
he must increase and I must
decrease he must increase and I must
decrease did I tell you I came I'm not
the groom I'm the friend of the groom
the bridegroom right he must increase I
must
decrease if you read from John 3:27 to
31 oh yeah he's
there you see it uhhuh it goes why are
you upset about me I told you it's not
about me it's not about me it's about
him every good gift is from God comes
from above he must increase I must
decrease right and I'm not the groom I'm
the friend of the groom and the friend
rejoices when the groom
comes he it's about him
right so that's what he's doing with the
disciples you're not here to follow me
you're following me
in so far and as long as he is not here
he's here now you must go to him and
forget me because it's not about
me that's awesome
right so either interpretation brother
okay he doubt it so what that's why I
didn't give you this explanation because
I wanted you to think deeper okay so he
doubt it why are you shocked
man don't you read read your Bible
people are seeing God visibly pillar of
cloud Pillar of Fire seeing Miracles the
plagues Red Sea okay did not God split
the Red Sea before
Israel yeah and yet they still
complained in the desert and doubted God
and didn't trust that he had the power
to preserve them and they built a golden
calf in front of him to worship the
calf yeah help them because of pressure
because he's afraid if he didn't they
kill
him yeah and even they went to T God
because they were therey okay see so why
are you shocked that just because
someone saw God what is that going to
make them infallable impeccable no on
this side of Glory in these bodies we
are being perfected but until God
changes this body and removes that
sinful
inclination I'm going to struggle with
sin I'm going to succumb to sin I'm
going to fail God until the Lord
transforms my body or until I
die and dwell with God in heaven then
I'm perfected and when I return that
body comes out perfected free of sin but
until then why are you shocked that's
the message of the Bible